après la réaction vous fait vous allez
travailler monsieur chez vous et gardez
tous les attributs de combat quoi le
blog voici le meilleur exemple d'une
cacophonie
les gens n'ont rien sur oise je suis
second non j'ai pas que je combats
étaient uniques tab là dessus ce qui est
à dire c'est que monsieur chiffre n'est
pas d'accord avec monsieur legault qui
va avoir des entrevues avec chaque
immigrant qui veut s'assurer d'avoir un
test de valeur pas d'accord et que sa
valeur
c'est vrai est en train de dire
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont régler la route
roxane vous ne réglez pas ici on veut
vraiment avoir plus d'une grande nature
économique
il faut avoir moins de réfugiés et c'est
ce qu'on veut faire on veut aider les
vrais réfugiés coulant riblon dans les
régions vers l'est merci monsieur
bernier jugèrent 10 secondes monsieur
blanchet 10 secondes je vais appris à
utiliser les réfugiés qui quittent la
guerre civile qui quittent les désastres
naturels par qui vit de l'état de new
york et je vais régler le fait dans le
tronc de les faire appliquer les mêmes
principes dans le dos les boeufs les
endroits comme braque second on va
assurer que notre système qu'on se
serait montrée soulagée
deux choses appliquer l'article 10 de
l'entente entre les tiers pays sûrs pour
fermer le chemin oxame et forcer les
gens à passer par les vrais passer au
palier c'est souvent de respecter la
démocratie c'est sûr les gens ont le
droit très bien haut